hi this is Scott Butterworth standing in
for reviewer Peter Brown if you've ever
stepped into samus aran's boots for a
Metroid adventure you'll instantly
recognize parallels and head Landers
world structure outfits and animations
on the other hand years of experience
with Samus can't prepare you for head
Lenders lead character ahead in a
rocket-powered jar without a body to
call home
you have to decapitate robots and steal
their bodies to fight back this is but
one of many refreshing concepts on
display not least of which is a stylized
70s sci-fi aesthetic that's immediately
appealing
this side-scrolling adventure takes
place in a world populated by hedonist
robots who at any given moment are
trippin out trying to get laid or
dancing just another day in the Pleasure
Dome
you're guided through this odd world by
a man named Earl a voice on the other
side of your communication equipment
who's trying to help you escape the
clutches of Methuselah the lead AI Earl
southern drawl and lackadaisical
personality are a breath of fresh air
portraying level-headed and helpful
gentlemen in a sea of far-out characters
when Earl first jars you from your deep
sleep you awake in a state of shock
without a body's you can't speak or fire
back at gun-toting robots as you venture
through the Pleasure Dome and into the
belly of Methuselah fortress you take
over robot bodies to gain access to
weapons and security doors
robot bodies are color-coded to security
levels and lasers can be used to open
doors if you can't walk up to them with
a body intact this becomes necessary for
one very important reason you can't jump
it's a weird omission at first blush but
once you get used to flying your head
around in low gravity a satisfying
experience on its own you quickly forget
why you cared about the lack of jumping
in the first place your head has
unlimited propulsion and vacuum power
and it's graceful in flight carrying
momentum and turning on a dime if it
needs to
every victim you possess has its own
life bar but the one associated with
your helmet is the one that really
matters thankfully it replenishes
automatically over a short period of
time even if you manage to die het
lander is extremely forgiving allowing
you in most cases to respawn in the same
room the only exceptions are multistage
boss fights and objectives where you're
forced to restart from the beginning of
your task upon death this is really only
troublesome during the games - boss
fights where death comes to the drop of
a hat should you fly erratically or
wander into a projectile on your way to
methuselah doorstep you're sent on a lot
of fetch quests but it isn't as bad as
it sounds
pets contain battle sequences and
puzzles that require you to definitely
swap bodies and survive stretches of
hazardous corridors to arrive at your
destination with a specific type of
robot well the shooting could be better
it's twitchy nature isn't damming
frustration is inevitable when you're
carefully aiming shots and enemies keep
responding and firing at you but these
occasions rarely require more than two
or three attempts to overcome
once in a pop when you aren't dead set
on accomplishing a mission you can veer
the corners of maps and hunt for
upgrades or for large doses of energy
which you can invest in the abilities
that manifest when you inhabit a body
the biggest upgrade your head gets is a
powerful - but there are numerous
powerful upgrades that activate when you
pilot bodies including a rainbow-colored
armored aura and the ability to abandon
bodies that continuously fire their
weapons essentially turning them into
turrets it takes the entire game to gain
enough energy to unlock every upgrade
but it seems like incremental upgrades
for your helmet lie in wait around every
other corner the ten or so hours it
takes to beat headliner are packed with
glimmering visual effects and great
tunes that range from light-hearted
lounge music to overbearing synth tracks
it's a weird and infectious world that
feels like the perfect playground for
head Landers quirky and engaging action
there's rarely a bump in the road that
proves significant enough to disrupt the
joys of flying around as a head
decapitating robots and taking over
bodies against the game's absurd and
colorful backdrop
while Headley unders parallels to
Metroid bubble under the surface if the
game's fresh qualities that grab your
attention and make it one of the most
delightful takes on the well-worn
formula in Gears